mon père quand j'étais petit je me
disais
ce qui est vraiment aveugle parce que
rien ne passait 600 qu'ils soient au
courant on passait sur de la moquette il
entendait céder le pouvoir et tu vois il
fait semblant d'être aveugle et après et
avant la machine tout seul prend le
métro les toutous seuls des trucs
il me guide c'est moi qui conduis c'est
lui qui me dit on à gauche tourne à
droite pas de vent on s'arrête là après
tel mettront ces telle taxation cette
constation non mais c'est incroyable et
plus grande c'était croire tout ce qu'il
a fait malgré qu'ils soient aveugles
s'il s'était présenté à la présidence de
la république
et bien ne rien obama noirs dans une
riche année comme présidente marguerite
malgré son handicap il a fait beaucoup
beaucoup de choses
c'est un exemple pour moi que j'ai
malade et que bute souvent mêlés
commun taille va faire tout ça si c'est
simplement dommage de l'exemple de mon
père je ne peux pas rester assis dans
mon coin ne rien faire alors que mon
père a fait tout ce qu'il a fait
donc c'est ça qui me fait avancer en me
disant bon ben je vois plus est devant
lui il a perdu la jalle à la vue à 18
ans moi j'ai perdu
on avait déjà eu 40 passé et pourtant
j'ai mon pâté le quart de ce qu'ils
voulaient donc ça c'est cema locomotive
c'est lui qui m'a permis d'avancer dans
plans de handicap et c'est lui qui m'a
aussi permis d'aider des autres
handicapés à mon père
déjà je sais qu'il a toujours en fait
depuis que je connais j'ai toujours dû
faire chanter
on affaiblit la physique il a fait du
théâtre
il a fait des composés il a créé la fin
du barça b est là
il est parti aujourd'hui et là je me
rends compte que ce que je en fait je
connaissais que l'eau de l'iss vers tout
ce qu'ils avaient en dessous franchement
j'ai c'est là que je me rends compte que
je rencontre vraiment que tout ce qu'il
a fait tout ce qu'il a fait j'étais un
monument un monument à rouiba immense
immense